13 deutsche kegelfreunde aus münster
party urlauber sind jetzt auf mallorca
im knast er wer von ihnen hat diesel bar
auf dem gewissen wer von ihnen hat
schuld dass das kleinod in el arenal die
aktion asche liegt die 13 kegelfreunde
schweigen
ja sie sind ja noch im gefängnis sind
sie sagen kein wort wie lange noch wie
lange hält ihr schweigen welcher
kegelbruder verrät seine freunde zuerst
und wie lange müssen alle 13 überhaupt
noch bleiben im knast auf palma de
mallorca
mehr als 72 stunden mehr als drei tage
gefangen im alle knast ihre familien
bangen auf dem gefängnis parkplatz des
centro benita jiao de mallorca offen auf
die freilassung ihrer söhne das
gefängnis ist den meisten urlaubern der
mittelmeerinsel zumindest von außen
bekannt nördlich von palma ein kalter
christa gebäudekomplex direkt neben der
ring autobahn und es ist das vorläufige
zuhause von 13 deutschen männer denn sie
schweigen
darüber der kegelverein aus münster 13
männer zwischen 24 und 29 jahre sie
wollen male sommer sonne strand und meer
doch stattdessen flammen feuer
festnahmen die 13
kegelbrüder aus dem münsterland hatten
einen feucht fröhlichen nachmittag
hinter sich gebracht und saßen dann hier
zusammen und sollen nach einer
zeugenaussage zunächst bier auf das
schiff geschüttet haben und danach die
aschen kippen hinterher geworfen haben
nur wenige sekunden steht das
angrenzende gebäude in flammen die
bahrain ort brennt lichterloh
die rauchwolke ist sogar bis an die
küste zu sehen und breitet sich auf
weitere gebäude aus der sachschaden mehr
als
150.000 euro übrig von der baar ist
nichts mehr ein großes klaffendes loch
eine ruine wo bis freitagnachmittag noch
die mine nordbahn stand
unfassbar sechs der 13 männer kämpfen zu
hause in münster gegen das was sie hier
anrichten feuer denn ein halbes dutzend
der mahle zündler sollen mitglieder der
freiwilligen feuerwehr sein einen tag
nach dem brand klicken die handschellen
anstatt spanische tapas und sangría gibt
es schwedische gardinen und
gefängniskost für die male zündler seit
samstagnachmittag sitzen die 13 männer
in untersuchungshaft
und diese untersuchungshaft die könnte
auf mallorca bis zu zwei jahre dauern
der richter hat offenbar so eine harte
sanktion verhängt weil keiner der 13
bisher angaben gemacht hat was an diesem
nachmittag gegen 14.30 hier wirklich
passiert es auf diesem balkon und so hat
er so eine art sippenhaft auf alle
verhängt und dadurch dass hier auch
menschen hätten zu schaden kommen können
droht ihnen auch eine strafe von mehr
als zehn jahren einmal trip wie eine
achterbahnfahrt vom flughafen über die
partymeile am ballermann hinein in den
knast solange die 13 kegelbrüder ihre
aussage verweigern ermittelt die grazer
zivil unter hochdruck wer aktiv am brand
beteiligt war und das kann tage wochen
oder monate dauern bis dahin bleiben die
männer in untersuchungshaft ohne kaution
und unser reporter jörg völkerling ist
auf mallorca york es ist ja wirklich
bemerkenswert wie sehr die kegel truppe
die zusammenhält verzweifelt da nicht
langsam auch die spanische justiz
nein die zeigt sich da sehr hartleibig
und man hat immer mehr den eindruck dass
auch ein exempel statuiert werden soll
an dieser art von st auf tourismus sogar
die mallorquinische regionalpräsidentin
francina armengol hat sich gestern zu
diesem fall geäußert und hat gesagt dass
es eine art von tourismus die wolle man
auf den balearen nicht mehr haben man
hatte ja gedacht durch corona sei hier
ein bisschen ruhe rein gekommen und man
könne jetzt etwas qualitativ
hochwertigen tourismus hier zelebrieren
aber wir sehen das seit die flieger nach
mallorca wieder starten es kommen hier
auch in dieser straße direkt gegenüber
und neben dem ausgebrannten lokal
weinort minütlich im zehn minuten takt
kommen die taxis an die die touristen
vor allem aus deutschland vom flughafen
bringen und laden weiter also weiter
touristen ab und die verdi die grünen
auch unbesorgt hier weiter durch die
gegend aber was man auch sieht seit
gestern ist hier etwas bewegung in den
fall gekommen denn neben den deutschen
party touristen sind jetzt auch die
angehörigen der 13 kegelbrüder auf
mallorca eingetroffen wie gestern
konnten ari so leist auf unsere kollegen
und nino lopez bereits auf dem parkplatz
vor dem gefängnis einige väter und
mütter sehen die versuchten zu ihren
kindern zukommen sie wurden aber nicht
hineingelassen am abend dann fand ein
treffen mit zwei deutschen anwälten
statt darunter ein wirklicher
hochkaräter ein sehr bekannter
strafverteidiger aus deutschland der
jetzt die koordination der verteidigung
übernommen hat man will jetzt mit
spanischen rechtsexperten mit spanischen
rechtsanwältin abwägen welche chancen es
gibt diese 13 rauszuholen und auch
abwägen ob es vielleicht doch noch eine
aussage gibt bisher halten alle zusammen
alle vereine und einer für alle niemand
spricht er bricht das schweigen aber das
ist vielleicht in diesem fall keine so
ganz kluge taktik weil die
untersuchungshaft in spanien kann bis zu
zwei jahre dauern vor allen dingen wenn
eine so harte strafe bis zu zehn bis 20
jahre dahinter steht weil hier
menschenleben gefährdet worden sein
könnten